j'ai
l'honneur au nom du Gouvernement de la
République de demander à l'Assemblée
nationale l'abolliition de la peine de
mort en France et puisque vous avez
prononcé tout à l'heure le nom de deux
condamnés à mort et de deux exécutés je
vous dirai pourquoi est-ce que plus
qu'aucun autre je sais qu'il n'y a pas
dans la peine de mort de valeur
dissuasiv sachez bien que dans la foule
qui a trois cré au passage de buffet et
de bon temps autour du palais de justice
à mort buffet à mort bon temps se
trouvait un jeune homme qui s'appelait
Patrick Henry croyez-moi à ma
stupéfaction quand je l'ai appris j'ai
compris ce que ce jour-là pouvait
signifier la valeur dissuasive de la
peine de
[Applaudissements]
mort